[Music]
jc is with us in las vegas hi jc what's
up
hi dave hi john how are you guys
great how can we help
um
so i have a very unsteady income um i
have a degree
and i was working in my field for a
little while and i um just decided not
to do that anymore um i was teaching
and um without with covet and everything
it was a little too much um for me but
right now my unsteady income like i'm
not making ends meet and i'm trying to
get out of debt and do the debt snowball
and get a thousand dollars in my
emergency fund and it's it's just a lot
it's just discouraging and i'm trying to
find another job but um but going to job
fairs nobody's hiring me
um i just don't know what to do i feel
stuck
[Music]
why'd you quit teaching
um i
i was teaching out in las vegas in the
schools i grew up in the midwest so the
school um i'm just like not used to this
demographic and
um
oh it was just
too much and there was like 50 kids
under my
like i was in charge of 50 kids by
myself and it was just it was a lot to
handle
and i wasn't getting any support
so it wasn't teaching that was bothering
you you got in an unwieldy situation
yeah
yeah yeah so teaching is not the problem
right it's you know poorly managed
school school with bed leadership yeah
yeah
that was the problem so what would be
wrong with going back to teaching then
if you had if you had my teaching life
30 students and a people who behaved
yeah i mean that would be that would be
fine too i mean i tried to go out to um
ohio and teach and i had 30 kids and it
was it was fine and then covet hit and i
was teaching online and then i was
teaching kindergartners online and it
was like it was very difficult for me
yeah but they're back now um so i
thought about
i'm sorry they're back now
yeah yeah
um i thought about like maybe starting
my own piano studio um that way then i
can still teach
um
and it would be a little bit better but
i'm not sure okay
well i mean you've identified the
problem the problem is you don't make
enough money
and the way you solve the problem uh no
kidding dave is you make more money so
uh that's why we're that's what we're
saying that's what john and i are both
sitting here poking at what's the
shortest distance between where you are
and more money because the first step
with your job is not self-actualization
the first step is not finding your
purpose the first step is eating food
yes and lights and stuff like that and
that's where you're struggling and so
you know you know and
so if you're going to continue to do
uh the thing you're doing you're going
to do a whole lot more of it or you've
got to change gears get in a different
lane
and um
you know not take the scars of covid and
the scars of a poorly chosen first
teaching gig with 50 kids and just say
that rules out my entire teaching career
based on those two experiences of very
weird situations
so i don't know but what's the shortest
distance like what can you be doing by
january one that pays you four times
more than you're making now a lot of
stuff actually
and not random things at a job fair
things that you've already been trained
for
so that's what i would aim at hang on
i'll send you a copy of ken's book
paycheck to purpose
it'll help you move in that direction